monsieur le ministre nous ne céderons
pas à votre chantage qui consiste à
opposer en toutes circonstances la
protection de la santé et la sauvegarde
des libertés
[Musique]
ce pass
nous voilà donc convoqué un 29 décembre
entre la bûche de noël et les voeux du
nouvel an pour avaliser en un temps
record votre décision de créer deux
catégories de citoyens dans notre pays
les français vaccinés d'une part et les
non vaccinés ou les sans schéma vaccinal
complet d'autre part qui ne pourront
plus aller au restaurant au cinéma au
théâtre au café aux clubs de sport
associatif ou qui perdront leur travail
purement et simplement
[Musique]
comme l'a répété le premier ministre il
faut faire peser la contrainte sur les
non vaccinés alors à bas les non
vaccinés
l'hôpital public est à bout de souffle
rien à voir avec les dix sept mille neuf
cents lits fermés pendant votre
quinquennat dont 5700 lit en 2020 en
pleine pandémie rien à voir avec les 4
milliards d'euros retirés à l'hôpital
public où les 14 milliards d'économies
faites sur le dos de la sécurité sociale
ni avec la souffrance des soignants
ignoré alors qu'il manifestait pour des
moyens humains et financiers un an avant
l'épidémie
[Musique]
si nous partageons une impérieuse
nécessité de renforcer la campagne
vaccinale nous sommes pas favorables à
tout acte d'autorité voire d'
autoritarisme de nature à fracturer à
cliver chaque jour un peu plus la
société française vous ne cessez de
durcir à chaque étape on risque de vous
contredire les atteintes aux libertés
fondamentales
[Musique]
n'a voté contre toutes les mesures
depuis le premier projet doit vous êtes
en cohérence avec vous même donc les
procès à la fois en déni de démocratie
quand c'est le douzième texte de loi je
viens défendre devant la représentation
nationale et le procès en cloisonnement
et en fermeture du pays écoutez quand on
se compare même le député
on se console merci
[Musique]